[Music]
you want to know Dutch why they keep
coming here you have this dying
the ich Redemption my Maker I do
you
[Music]
see youtubers happy Super Bowl weekend
so we got new transformers let's break
it down
gladiator robots fighting for the future
of Cybertron on the earth just feel so
appropriate Super Bowl weekend if you
have no idea what's going on don't worry
it's just like a comic-con style weekend
when a whole bunch of trailers are
dropping so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll be doing a couple fun
giveaways and I'll remind everyone at
the end of this which other big trailers
have been confirmed and when they're
coming but you can kind of seat like as
Optimus Prime is fighting bumblebee here
they're sort of setting him up for his
spin-off movie there will be a bumblebee
standalone film in addition to all these
saga transformer films so this just
paints a little clearer picture that
Optimus Prime is positioned as the
villain in the same way that DOM is the
villain of the Fast and the Furious
movies that's going to be happening
really soon too but they released the
synopsis and Michael Bay did this big
interview about the crazy writers room
that they had about spinning the
mythology out for this big film universe
that they're doing because they'll be
this bumblebee standoff films and
they'll be doing their saga film so they
basically had to re-engineer the
Transformers mythology so that it would
fit within this giant film universe so
they had everybody that had ever worked
on transformers come in and explained
the mythology to them so does reason
synopsis here the last night shatters
the core myths of the Transformers
franchise so they're talking about the
movies the toys all the stuff that
they've done so far redefine what it
means to be a hero humans and
transformers are at war Optimus Prime is
gone like you see him floating off in
space in the trailer the key to saving
our future lies buried in the secrets of
the past in the hidden history of the
Transformers on earth so that's where we
see the Transformers during the time of
King Arthur we see this dragon
transformer flying around saving our
world falls upon the shoulders of an
unlikely Alliance Cade Yeager who's Mark
Wahlberg's character for the most recent
film bumblebee in English Lord who's
Anthony Hopkins character in an Oxford
professor that's Laura Haddix character
there comes a moment in everyone's life
when we are called upon to make a
difference in transformers the last
night the hunted will become heroes so
they're talking a little bit about May
Tron with his giant sword here he
actually looks really badass in this
movie the new character this young girl
here with the squeaks robot she's going
to be stepping up becoming a hero and
heroes will become villain talking about
Optimus Prime
poisoned by the dark Energon one world
will survive theirs or ours so that just
confirms that this planet is basically
the remains of Cybertron from the
previous film not the last one it was
Transformers Dark of the Moon where they
basically teleported the remains of
Cybertron into outer space and they were
going to replace the earth with that so
what they've done is instead of like
doing a completely different story for
the sequel is they sort of leave the
mythology of all the films that have
come so far in sort of recontextualized
that Optimus Prime at the end of the
last movie went looking for the creators
there are mysteries to the universe we
were never meant to solve but who we are
and why we are here are not among them
those answers we carry inside I am
Optimus Prime and this message is to my
creators leave planet Earth alone
because I'm coming for you if you've
been watching transformers for a long
time they have a couple creator myth in
Primus is the original creator of the
Transformers he's like this multiversal
being that exists inside the center of
Cybertron he's like a special computer
that's sort of like webbed into
everything that the Transformers are so
when Optimus Prime says that he's
seeking Redemption and hear that female
voice he might be in the bowels of
Cybertron so when it sounds like they're
playing with the core myths of the
Transformers franchise it sounds like
they're playing with their creation myth
so optimus prime gets co-opted by the
forces of cybertron to try and renew
their planet at the expense of the earth
so it looks like some time has passed
since the last film and there's been all
out war between the Transformers in the
humans so in the time that Optimus Prime
blasted off at the end of the last movie
things have just gone completely nuts so
I just love reading through Michael
Bay's interview talking about how they
brought in transformers historians
anything like super Cente or Power
Rangers that have been around for a long
time
always has experts that rise up so you
can see like a bunch of transformers
professors sitting around the table
talking about the mythology it just
sounds so cool if you've heard of the
Lucasfilm archives where they keep
everything Star Wars they made a version
of that for the Transformers franchise
you know for all the big films for all
the stuff that they're going to be doing
so I wouldn't be surprised if there is
like a giant resurgence of transformers
in pop culture it's always been pretty
popular but typically what you see is
you have like a bunch of young kids to
get hooked on the new animated series
going to see the movies so let me know
what you think of this so far and the
cool thing is is they will be releasing
a longer
version of this on Sunday so I'll do
another video there'll be a bunch of new
footage and let me know what you think
about the new trend in movies with
Heroes going bad for good reasons that
aren't totally explained like you can
see the reaction they're going for from
the trail like they want you to freak
out because Optimus Prime is trying to
kill bumblebee he has the dark Energon
eyes but clearly he's still a good
character so they're not going to make
him irredeemable so it seems like in his
failure the forces of cybertron give him
a second chance but in doing so also
turn him bad for a little while it's
like the classic Transformers film where
the defeated Megatron comes upon Unicron
gets a second chance and becomes
Galvatron so it almost seems like this
is a reverse version of that for Optimus
Prime so I'm going to have to spend some
time this weekend re watching the
animated movie it's been a while then
watching some of the live-action movies
again I super bowl's here there's going
to be a bunch of awesome trailers this
is just the beginning there'll be some
guardians of the galaxy the other big
trailers that are dropping are pirates
which is another paramount movie just
like transformers there's more fast and
furious and then obviously guardians of
the galaxy so as those posts I will post
new videos so they might be dropping
across the weekend they might all drop
on Sunday I'll try to do as many of them
as possible and there will be Marvel
giveaways when I post those Marvel
videos but there will be some new Star
Wars Episode eight later tonight while
you wait for that to post you can click
here to learn which Guardians have been
confirmed for infinity war and you can
click here for my Star Wars Episode 8
Snoke video thank you so much for
watching everybody
since at 5:00 I'll see you in the next
video